it well i think because these things are
going on mike that it's important the
world is basically burning around us and
it's important for us to cover the
things that really matter
so stuttering john talked about us on
his podcast and i think
you remember like i was there remember
when shulie
and benji remember those guys oh yeah
yeah those guys man they were cool guys
this whole show now it's so sad now i
think it's important to point out that
uh
under federal copyright law we are
allowed to provide transformative
commentary and criticize this public
figure the public figure john melendez
also an ak known as stuttering john
we will be providing uh transformative
comment commentary
and especially now that this is
newsworthy in our community because he
specifically referenced us and i think
as anybody
we should be able to defend ourselves
we should be able to defend ourselves to
the accusations that stuttering john is
making to us
in his california home so uh let's see
what he said
a little silent in the past but i think
it's time
that i address the trolls and the
[ __ ] haters
for what they are are they trolls and
haters john
cool young handsome hip guys i mean yeah
i agree with him cool and fun yeah cool
and fun john
seriously are you really gonna listen
or really follow i'm sorry can i just
can i just point something out because i
just went back to the tab of uh
us our show
the [ __ ] quality of the video for us
versus his versus what's underneath
is it's eats staggeringly bad
and let's not even mention the quality
of the person
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you loser i think it's time that
i address
the trolls and the [ __ ] haters for
what they are
[ __ ] haters man haters man i've been
doing this for
eight years 18 years old
seriously are you really gonna listen
or really follow two bald fat losers in
their mom's basement
yes john i you know you're not the first
guy i've had to correct on this
on this uh couple points uh my mom's
dead
i don't know she was sick it was a
national tragedy
secondly we live in florida the water
table
uh is very high in the state of florida
it doesn't allow for one to have a
basement there's no basement here which
sucks because honestly basements are
like free realist it's free real estate
it's like they're great but we can't
have them here
so you're wrong on two points john also
yeah yeah we can lose a little weight
sure
but i mean are we even fat by american
standards at this point
i mean i'm pretty fat uh
but john is like we saw your stand-up
john you're not the figure of fitness
talking over here all right
get out of here [ __ ] you mr we think
you're [ __ ] adonis body
i mean really the guys are [ __ ]
losers my wife still loves me
[Music]
i do like the john that that was his big
comeback
john it's just over enunciating the word
losers
he nailed us don't you love when we do
this fair use stuff
john you do your show for [ __ ] 72
people and 68 of them are our fans
who's the [ __ ] loser you can't pull
we we pull consistently at least 2
000 most of the time 2500 listeners in
one in one shot on one site not even
counting the other sites
you can't even pull the numbers on
youtube that we pull on d
live and like that's just d live
somebody goes royce i sleep in a big bed
with my wife
i sleep behind the wheel of a [ __ ]
sports car
it's like this is the worst the worst
chance you change the voice actor for
milhouse's dad
yeah can i borrow a feeling
john works at a [ __ ] cracker factory
legitimate losers
and you got this other podcast out there
oh
oh we're going to make fun of all
different podcasts
we're going to make fun of the hundreds
of thousands we're going to show you
all the podcasts that are out there
first off by the way just a reminder we
will be we will be on who are these
podcasts uh actually this weekend
recording it's gonna be fun what's funny
is right we were making fun of this
video at the airport last night
like we're [ __ ] it was great because
vegas has a little boxes where you could
just smoke and play slots
so we're just smoking i'm smoking we're
playing slots and [ __ ] just getting
ready to go home
and we're talking about this video and i
specifically brought that point up i'm
like
i'm like i love that he doesn't have any
material he's just describing
things he's two fat guys making fun of
people
what's with the sauna show uh we're
going to listen to podcasts and then
we're going to do reviews and make fun
of them
so i was like a great idea i was doing
that last night and i turned to royce
and i go
yeah when you think about it's actually
pretty genius because you're always
pulling people from these new fan bases
i'm like no when you think about it it
was the most simple and elegant idea for
a show ever
let's literally cover every show and
beef with everyone over time
john comment so do we want to talk about
that
you know when did evan weiss become his
co-host
thanks for having me it's really nice to
be here john
they're supposed to be hey vinnie you're
there
i'm here buddy okay i'm just talking
about all these podcasts
that's his lawyer and actually you know
evan weiss always had a cool brother
with money
that took care of him yeah so that's
that's what i imagine uh evan
brother would be joe but that's what i
assume this would be like evan's brother
all right fine i'll get you another
thousand dollars get away from me
out there that you know but
there's one out there that's supposed to
make fun and supposed to tell you
they're supposed to be doing a service
to other people
by [ __ ] you know telling them what
pog get
to watch john your entire career was
basically that show but goofing on
celebrities
like your entire career was going out
there and doing
wacky interviews and making fun of
celebrities how dare you sir you
you don't get to judge people for now
monetizing and doing
doing something better than you ever did
and there's a lot of people going joe
what's on howard
let me tell you howard stern would have
been just as famous
without [ __ ] stuttering john
stuttering john wasn't the goddamn
linchpin of that show
and no matter what [ __ ] what this
[ __ ] idiot tells you
what what what this what this wannabe
guido tells you
that's not what would happen or to
listen to
and what podcast to not listen to yet
every week all they talk about is my
podcast
that's not true they've talked about
several podcasts i will tell you this
week we would be talking about your
podcast oh yeah
yeah that will be happening definitely
definitely mike i just want to point
something out
that under federal copyright law on the
millennium copyright act
we are providing transformative content
yeah we're commenting a lot
transformative content and commentary
for these clips that we are playing
and in no way or is our playing these
clips uh uh
uh competing with the uh full commercial
product that john provides
absolutely not because who would want to
watch us
just keep interrupting you know what i
mean so it's like yeah that's you know
let's just see you guys
so you guys should actually go check
this video out too
i'd say that right encourage i want
people to go see this video and support
john as well
and our youtube channel is not monetized
so nowhere are we profiting yeah
no from uh criticizing you yeah
they're so unprofessional too no
how dare you how can this guy call how
how dare you you you you didn't even pay
for the full license for stream yard
that's why the stream yard logo's up on
the right top that's why
and by the way streaming orders it's
[ __ ] trash yes
but to me vinny look yo vinny i know i'm
not
as relevant as george clooney
you're not as [ __ ] relevant as george
costanza
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
i know i'm not as relevant as
howard stern well howard stern's not as
relevant as howard stern
but even still he's more relevant than
him
but if i was if i'm so irrelevant
right irreverent irrelevant
he's so irrelevant [ __ ] [ __ ]
you are a dumb man jackass is what he is
relevant then why do these two bald fat
losers
in their basements you know trash me
every week
why does this [ __ ] loser in rochester
who is a partner in a marketing firm
you mean raj i think his name is carla
what
is he trying to dox [ __ ] who are
these podcasts is that what he's doing
is is that what you're doing johnny boy
that's not very cool
that's not cool or fun yeah it's not
very cool see what trip thinks about
this
although rochester makes sense with all
the shows they make fun of yeah
that really does make sense now it's all
metropolis [ __ ]
why why if i'm such a loser
and i'm so irrelevant why do they take
the time
out of every show to address me and this
podcast
you go first sure because you're doing
this
because you are an idiot and it's funny
yeah because
honestly we would have this it would
have been a one and done with us with
you but then you had to decide that you
were gonna be a big boy you made it
worse john
you made it worse john you made it worse
you made it way worse john
yeah and i just have to add like we've
always joked about
people who are terrible who have blown
great opportunities and are now
really really sad and stinking up
youtube see john what you don't
understand is you don't have to be
relevant
but you're in our house now this is our
house
okay we didn't we didn't see us [ __ ]
sniffing around
stern studios back in the day or trying
to get in on the tonight show and if we
had you should have had us thrown out of
the building well this is
our house now so we have to police it
and we can't have people like you
going around stinking the joint up it's
bad for everyone
so i'm going to skip a little bit ahead
here while we uh while we continue this
transformative content
the transformative content we're
providing is so fair use it's crazy
many many presidents have upheld it
somebody said in the chat this is the uh
the best case of transformative content
they've ever seen
oh and john just a heads up too you know
sargon of akkad he just uh
got sued and uh he won his lawsuit uh
under fair use and the judge declared
that he was able to now sue the person
who sued him originally for legal fees
for the legal fees so just keep that in
mind too john that um
you know any any [ __ ] money we'd have
to waste in court which would just be
silly
uh we we would plan on suing you for yes
immediately
like like that day as soon as it's
uh um so i'm skipping a little bit oh
sure now mike i i want to be honest with
you i know they tell you not to insert
yourself in things
but i was bored we were waiting to do
stuff in vegas
hanging out and somebody was like i
think you were still you were still
sleeping a little bit
and uh got a message going hey man
stuttering john's and i'm like oh me
check out let me help
a fellow content creator so i hopped on
i sent him a little bit of money oh no
what
i sent him a little bit of money anytime
you or i donate it's never good
yeah it's never a noise like mike i
apologize i didn't i didn't consult you
but i did spend five dollars of our
money
i i can't believe you i already asked
for a refund i can't believe you would
[ __ ] violate our
account like five dollars has been spent
um and i hope this was worth it and now
this is when he really talks and i'm
going to notice that especially you know
even just coming back from vegas i'll be
able to notice
five bucks i'll be like whoa where is
this from
john a 32 bobby ojeda uh got into the
boat accident with the indians yeah yeah
oh your boys are there revenge of the
set oh there they are
just oh oh whoa that's funny you need to
fight owls more than we
do
that's a pretty but he's not quick like
bro he destroyed you he's
he's [ __ ] just so dumb he did he just
just
like that that's you dude that's what
you're saying
he judy [ __ ] i don't know man i think
i kind of want to do a show with john
i think the problem is and there's this
look i'm not going to lie mike it is a
very good impression if you to work on
it though you have to be successfully
married
your wife left you oh you're
kicked off from the start show she took
the house
and a little just used me as a revenge
[ __ ] to get to howard that's all it was
it was a revenge [ __ ] that's all it was
john oh wait mike transformative content
thank you for the federal law thank you
much appreciate it
how long did they read the whole thing i
you know how do i get you know how do i
pull it up
i'll read it john ask your ex-wife's
boyfriend if you're allowed to call into
our show
okay look that was me you said that
jesus christ
i said that i was being i was getting a
little salty
i was a salty boy i was a salty boy
salty boy and i'm sorry i apologize
wow i want to apologize i apologize look
can i apologize to john oh [ __ ] can i
apologize to john
that's just mean can i apologize sam
sure
this is emmanuel rodriguez the guy who
plays royce lopez on the show
and i just wanted to say that um your
wife is currently being [ __ ] by a
man half black
it's it's very strong and um
i believe that um you would have to ask
his permission since she
holds your not only testicles but wallet
in your purse in her purse excuse me
um shall we continue with the
transformative content
absolutely all right let's transform
some of this content
okay i don't i don't get it well of
course
you know you know i don't get anything
they say because they you know because
you barely speak english
seriously because you're a bumbling fool
i don't think they said that's something
you know somebody james schneider in the
chat pointed out too that uh starring
john's wife is a real
brian cowan oh yeah she really is she's
a real brian cowan
you thought you were going to get but
you got guys but you got caught you got
god
lives i don't you know i don't even care
that you know i mean you know you can
say this
i'm not funny on this podcast fine i
don't well no no no i never said you
weren't funny on this podcast
i said you weren't funny at all yeah in
general in life
and anything your life is hilarious
you are the joke some people want to
make jokes but you are you are
the joke john you are the joke i don't
really give a [ __ ]
you know you take my interviews in
general and and the ones that you put up
on your site that are uh
copyright yours they're not yours not
yours that i could see your lawyers
advise you to take down because you took
them down
[Laughter]
john
[Laughter]
john john there's more
bloody there even that stutter was
funnier than anything these [ __ ]
douchebags have done in their lives
that's not true a fake stutter is
funnier than
that's not true anything we've ever done
i mean i i called roddy piper once and
convinced him i was jesse ventura that
was hilarious
it's better than anything you've ever
done john
i mean i made aj benzo going to coke
field rage
yeah that was a lot hilarious sorry
let's go back to uh
not so stuttering john so i'm sorry
we're pausing a lot guys but i don't
know if you know this
federal copyright law requires requires
provide transformative content and
commentary
right and of course this time it's very
transformative because we are addressing
we're making it funny
you're right it's a completely different
show
oh [ __ ] all right that was mean i'm
sorry john look it wasn't as mean as his
guy [ __ ] your wife comment but it was
still mean i don't know she was sick
my interviews alone and i'll put that up
against any of these other people oh
yeah the interviews that jackie wrote
for you the questions that jackie wrote
for you yeah those interviews
are those the ones that's right it was
all during the jackie days too
and he was the one that wrote all the
mean shitty questions
a cast way way funnier put any of my
work on stern
i'll get and i'll put these up against
these [ __ ] people
anymore yeah but you know you got to
stop hey john
you got to stop clinging to the glory
days
they're over yeah [ __ ] uncle rico
stop citing [ __ ] you did 20 years ago
you [ __ ]
you're the [ __ ] loser john we haven't
we never had connections we were never
on the stern show
we never were a part of all these people
we didn't have jay leno's number you did
and you've somehow managed to [ __ ]
destroy all of that uh don't say i
haven't had connections i don't
appreciate that i'm friends with big a
you're right it's all right and don't
you know bobo
we have connections that's not fair it's
not fair to say things like that to us
somebody says broke-ass barney rubble
looking [ __ ]
he really does he really he does why
they keep making fun of me bond
god [ __ ] losers
and i love how bald guys like to grow to
be at vince
do you ever notice that it's like
they're overcompensating
because they don't have any hair on
their head so they figure well let me
just show that
that i have had it's such a talk about
insecure
i'll have you know that my beard was
complimented by several young ladies in
las vegas
yeah mine was mostly mocked but i still
have
hair so that's cool she was really drunk
though to be fair
yeah yeah mine was mocked ruthlessly but
i do have hair
john i mean i know i get it i'm thinning
and all that but i still have hair
you know what else i have in your right
i don't have my hair jump but know we
know what we have
viewers that's true notice most bald
guys
except yourself fins mo except you bro
he just realized
you're cool hey you should get a free
bowl of soup with this hat
just kidding it looks good on you though
small guys grow beards and the reason
for that is they want to show
that they have some hair somewhere
because they're so insecure
about their fat bald stupid heads that
they got to grow a beard
i mean it's amazing to me like whereas
you used to have a beard but she left
you john
so look i don't want again like your old
boss howard has a beard
yeah there's another beer uh listen john
yes i am i'm baldin and i have a beard
here you're absolutely right
um but i know how the internet works um
i don't have a microphone that i got
from [ __ ] radio shack
and again we have viewers and look you
could revel in your glory days that's
that's perfectly fine we were having a
little light ribbon we were having a
little light ribbon
light teasing we're just having fun and
now you made me go and look up what
transformative content is
you think i want to do that work john
yeah that's what i feel like doing i'm
tired i'm [ __ ] sleepy nobody wants to
do work
i'm [ __ ] sleepy today
do you think that you think that i
should be in school
i should be in school uh suzanna's
boyfriend
wouldn't allow you to call their show
vince you're not helping him here bud
i mean are you are you are you [ __ ]
torpedoing him i think he does are you
really torpedoing him
there's a there's a growing theory uh
that vince is just trolling him because
if you watch the show
there's a lot of moments that are just
weird and people are like
this guy's not helping john but he
doesn't seem stupid enough to not
know what he's doing like he does [ __ ]
like that like it's just very funny
it almost reminds me of uh he almost
reminds me of like cousin dan
like the way he [ __ ] with him like it's
very subtle but you're like
oh that's not a great freeze frame i
hope no one screen caps that
yeah that would be a bad freeze frame
[Music]
if we ask him i'm i'm i'm sorry
i could give him i'm sure he would is he
john you're [ __ ] so
stupid can you get jackie to [ __ ]
write for you for this
i'll tell you what john let's do this
you want to help him i'm going to help i
think i'm going to help
so here's what we'll do for you we'll
make all of this go away
we'll stop bugging you pay us a little
bit
we'll punch up your [ __ ] what do you
think i like that i'm gonna punch up his
show a little bit we have some jokes for
him
write some jokes a couple of jokes yeah
frogs that what so anyway i was at
scores right with artie
so i was always hooker walks up to me
and i'm like hey i'm stuttering john and
she's like yeah baby you can be whatever
you want if you pay me
what the [ __ ] do i care first of all
it's not you've been talking about it
for a while
it seems like you care a little bit a
boyfriend it's a fiancee
she's getting married in july
the the details of it don't help
wow he's this guy you [ __ ] hand him a
shovel he'll just keep digging he is not
a smart man
yeah no but i don't but i don't really
give a [ __ ] like i don't understand what
i mean is he restrictive with you in
terms of like what you can do
no he's [ __ ] i'm not gonna live
hey vince he's [ __ ] with him vince i
don't hate vince i kind of like
i like that vince mcmahon spun me over
jesus christ he's been
growing on me the more i've watched this
i'm like he's [ __ ] with john the
whole time
hey vince you want a job
hey manny want a job
i don't i barely talk to the man i mean
you know
look he's good to my kids i don't have
any problem with them but see spence
even that is more interesting than
anything he's [ __ ] you know
revenge of the [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
you know girl is
fat bald guys he's quick that's what
they say about him
revenge of the uh of
wow he's really he's really dumb he's
really quick
he's a really dumb guy hey can i because
i will die
vince you were invited on our show
please i would love to have you on man i
would love to talk to you
yeah vince come on let's come on vince
come on vince vince vincent
you know what vince unders i think look
i think vince understands this is a show
you know let's turn some people around
there's some people in this turn them
around on us
but he he's john just keeps getting
more and more mad doing their basement i
doubt those guys have been late in the
last [ __ ] two years
oh not crushing puss baby
you'd probably be wrong i would say
you're wrong i would say you're wrong
john i would i would have to i'd have to
say you're definitely wrong on this one
i promise you're wrong one of them i
mean look at them yeah that i agree with
no i mean they're [ __ ] they're like
bald fat losers in their basements
who have done nothing constructive in
their lives
oh yeah sorry we didn't walk up to gary
oldman and ask him how big his dick is
you're right you're [ __ ] right chad
constructive things like you've done
really funny when you think about it
john hasn't done anything really an
[ __ ]
ever in their lives had they done
anything constructive
they haven't made one person laugh in
their history well it's not true we're
making more people laugh than you
everything i've at least made one person
i've made mike laughs every
one single day we make thousands more
people laugh than you
in the millions every day how does it
feel
john to know that you had so many
opportunities
and so many connections and you can't
even scrape together
10 of our audience on youtube how does
that feel
john good because i'm okay with the fact
that we're not
i was never a [ __ ] stern i don't need
to be here's the thing john
without any help without any backing
without any [ __ ] connections
he and i have built one of the biggest
shows in the afternoon on youtube
you can't pull ten percent of our
numbers
you are the loser in the like there's no
way anybody looks at this equation and
goes
check out those two losers yeah but
remember when he asked lucy lawless how
big her tits were
john john john john
and they attack you know stuttering john
i made president obama laugh vince
listen to this humble brag you hear this
it's pathetic
i made president obama laugh
can you imagine that's your claim to
fame
you know what else made president obama
laugh in hospitals
yeah so i mean you're funny you're not
even funny in a [ __ ]
yeah you know who else made obama laugh
that guy who smoked crack in that limo
with him and then they sucked each
other's
remember that guy remember that story
you know you know what else made him
laugh
the bill for the hot dogs
[Laughter]
hey look they wrote hot dogs on it
that's hilarious
okay can they say that can yes i
actually uh i can't this is actually a
fact obama follows me on twitter sir
yeah i dm him all the time he doesn't dm
me back but he does follow me
they say that they made a president of
the united states land can they help
you yes yes we have and this is actually
true might get a test of this
um we actually cracked up george w bush
once
it's true it was at a gala yeah i got
the young child right in front of him
clapped like a [ __ ]
seal dude he was giggling he spilled his
beer it was [ __ ] hilarious
got real estate advice from the
president of the united states
yes and i do in battery park remember
what he told you
yeah stop doing this you're embarrassing
your family don't ever leave the stern
show
whatever you do it will be the stupidest
thing you've ever done
is to go not leave the stern show he
said i don't like land leases
you know i wouldn't do it but if you
really love it do it
it's terrible that's not advice that's
just somebody blowing you off nicely
so your claim the fame is obama politely
and only because he knows you from stern
politely
riffing with you for a couple minutes is
that
does that make you feel good inside john
huh
he's right so in battery park this just
a space of a land that they built but
it's rented to the city so when you own
space there
a condo there you don't technically own
it for the perpetuity for the rest of
your life it's a 99 year lease
so you've got advice from advice from
trump you got a flight from trump you
got hotel rooms from trump you
fought you won your fight at trump taj
mahal
and now trump is [ __ ] up the country
hey look uh
like you [ __ ] up your marriage he's a
smart guy he's he's
john's showing us his knowledge of
political affairs
yeah he's he's he's he's a man he's a
man about town and now he's [ __ ] up
the country
uh scan man 1967. here's a question for
you vince
where did all the stern videos go john
which star videos i guess on my youtube
channel
well you know i guess like you know you
know vince said you know
you know when you got these little
douche bags you know oh you know
everybody
everybody
go after john now oh go ahead i'm not
asking my fans to go after these [ __ ]
losers
no no you tried to do you're getting a
lawyer to come after you're getting a
lawyer coming after us and telling us to
take it down or else
you know but they oh come on let's get
everybody to go after john
wow how much energy are they [ __ ]
taking i don't know man you're the one
that got a lawyer involved
i mean again yeah we weren't really good
do you understand something i'm going to
say this and i'm sorry
this is from my favorite scene in street
fighter raul julia
when rotc entered your world it was the
biggest day of your life
for us it was a tuesday yeah
you get that john right you get that
right
but i can all go home
howard is getting paid off for his
crimes
[Laughter]
i'm going to kick that piece of [ __ ] out
stern
it's but what is it inside this ass so
hard kicked his ass back that the next
howard wannabe is gonna feel it
the next howard wallaby the next howard
wallop he's gonna feel it what a great
[ __ ] speech
now who wants to go home who wants to go
with me
to my apartment where i live with a
bunch of cats the
the best part of that movie is the
everybody doing their pose
at the end that's the best part of the
whole movie
i mean just i mean vince like like i
didn't want to talk about them anymore
but everybody keeps on
everyone's doing it because we weren't
doing a show that day and i was bored
yeah i was bored but everybody keeps
yeah cause we have more listeners than
you what'd you think was gonna happen
like putting their names on it but it's
like who the [ __ ]
like how much energy have they this is
the first time i've ever literally no
energy
i haven't slept in 24 hours yeah john
i've it's been a wild couple of days
and i haven't even had a moment neither
is he
to really [ __ ] with you we just you know
was bored
even really addressed these losers and
this will probably be the last time but
i mean
no it won't this will not be the last
time
john i just want to tell you something
john
you have here you go john i'm going to
do this for you i'm going to help you
out
you're more than welcome if you can
figure out how to do it you're more than
welcome to play our clips on your show
and provide transformative content yeah
go ahead
you will absolutely more than welcome
hey what's good for the goose
is good for the candor sure so please
you're more than welcome and just make
sure like you do what we're doing though
which is pause frequently uh hit on
points counteract
you know counter-argue the things you're
saying
because you are talking about us and we
are allowed to criticize you publicly
how much energy do they take in
addressing me
which which i always ask you who's a
bigger loser
you like vince is like uh-huh
[Music]
you're you're you're the bigger loser
john
the loser or the one who follows him hmm
yeah i'm trying to think look i i
thought the show was okay
i'm on vince's side now come on vance
come join the dark side
convince get your solos bro i'll get you
severe
you know what i'll tell you what vince
i'm gonna help you out
i'll help you out let's help you launch
your own show we'll give you the cousin
joe treatment you're a big star
you just you come over here you make
yourself a pro i'll play the promo on
this
i'll get we'll get you views vince i
promise you we'll get you
i'll get you a co-host cousin dan's not
doing anything of importance
he's with that loser joe but we can move
him more yeah we can move we'll move
some pieces around we're going to fire
joe
joe's fired he's not even working for us
he does his own show joe you're fired
poor joe i'm letting you guys joe right
now he's like come on man
[ __ ] christ they don't have a
charismatic bonus
you're under a non-compete so you can't
start a new show for another six months
sorry joe and you have to change the
name we own the names like wwe okay
all right you could be uncle joe you
could be uncle cracker
uncle joe yeah you could be weird uncle
joe he gets sued by joe biden
how about this new name for your show
nephew jimmy loser
the loser or the one who follows him
he's right these are all great clapping
look i i thought the show was okay
i thought it was funny they don't have a
charismatic bone in their body
hey how dare you john you could say
whatever you want about us
john from you i mean i i wouldn't even
mind if somebody said i didn't have a
charismatic bone in my body but you sir
will not be saying that to me and
getting away with it how dare you
how dare you hey
mike myers how big's your boner that's
basically all he did [ __ ] loser
you put you put me alone and a
microphone
against those two fat bald losers any
day of the week
all right i'll tell you what hey i like
a challenge
now i accept right now what do you think
mike
i accept a little roast battle i accept
i
i will in any day of the week john
any day of the week you want will
absolutely do it you pick
you pick you [ __ ] pick when and where
i we will fly out to california and do
it at your local chuckle hut
if you want yeah in a [ __ ] heartbeat
john come on john
here it is here's your chance there you
go don't lay down a challenge that
you're not gonna back up come on big guy
john i accept
no hesitation no money
no nothing right no nothing we don't
want anything you don't want okay
we're gonna make hey john out of our
pocket we're gonna make this
as easy as possible for you we'll come
to you
we don't want any pay no doing things
which not no making it complicated
no like well yeah but if you do it
you're gonna have to pick
no nope let's just come out we'll
beat the [ __ ] out of you and joke with
joe jokes of course
i mean roast battle-wise but we will
come out we will
absolutely put the boots to you in a
public setting
and get back on the plane and head home
you got our word
john challenge accepted
your move oh apparently at some point in
the little bit here he challenges us to
a boxing fight too
john we're not a bunch of [ __ ] fans
who do irl fighting sorry yeah that's
[ __ ] pretty you want to do comedy
versus comedy we'll do comedy versus
comedy and i know john i'm gonna do the
whole
oh cause she's scared huh no because you
just get to a certain age and you know
like i'm not gonna [ __ ] fight people
and in charge
if i were you i wouldn't get into a
[ __ ] boxing ring and i'm not accusing
you of this but i i heard something that
when you do cocaine for so long in your
life your heart doesn't do too good in
those situations yeah i don't want to
kill an old man just look
just [ __ ] comedy you want to do it
come on john
challenge accepted oh it'll be fun
please
whenever you want john whenever you want
well i will out entertain them
i mean there is not a question in my
mind that i will out entertain them
when are you going to start yeah john we
were really ahead of you too
and episode count like in in terms of
quality content
sketches production piece we're way
ahead of you john so you're gonna have
to start catching up
here's what i'm doing mike i'm gonna lay
down a challenge you ready
greco-roman wrestling hot oil
i like that somebody in the chats at
merch going full donga no
donga was the one that was like let's
fight in real life ah
let's fight in real life because i can't
come up with material i can't do content
let's fight
that was tonka
they don't have an entertaining bone in
their body
all they do is sit there and play other
people's videos
and [ __ ] trash other people yeah it's
hilarious
yes you're right
hey jason alexander you have a finger
elaine
that's entertainment though john right
pretty much his entire bit for years
hey kramer remember when you said the
n-word was that funny
they all they're hateful jealous
[ __ ] trolls
but we're funny yeah we have we do have
that going for us right
it's something